[Musik]
erzählen ist eine arznei gegen die
sterblichkeit das sagt mein heutiger
gast damit therapierte uns aber auch
sich selbst vermutlich zumindest seine
bücher wurden in mehr als 30 sprachen
übersetzt zahlreiche preise und
auszeichnungen hat er dafür erhalten die
rede ist vom österreichischen
schriftsteller christoph ransmayr er ist
ein wanderer zwischen den welten den
irdischen unten bei einer himmlischen
den mikroskopischen und den kosmischen
was findet er so viel sucht und soweit
sucht und wo nachforschte erzähler
ransmayr eigentlich dem möchte ich heute
nachgehen herzlich willkommen christoph
ransmayr schön sind sie hier dankeschön
ja ich bedanke mich für diese
geradezu großartige
begrüßung und willkommen heißen mit
gleich mit einem kleinen hinweis auf
einen der wege zu gott und womit könnte
man sich den kiefer verbeugen
nur auch dieser weg umfasst nur vier
oder fünf zeilen ich sah die heimat
eines gottes
ich sah die heimat eines gottes auf 26
grad 28 minuten südlicher breite und 105
grad 21 minuten westlicher länge eine
menschenleere von seevögeln umschwärmte
felsen insoweit weit draußen im pazifik
mehr als 3200 kilometer waren es von
diesen umrandeten baum und strauch losen
klippen ohne süßwasser ohne gras ohne
blütenpflanzen und muss bis zur
chilenischen küste von women's schiff
vor einer woche mit kurs auf rapa nui
die osterinsel ausgelaufen war vielen
dank das ist wirklich ein kurzer weg zu
gott weshalb haben sie sich entschieden
dass heute vorzulesen
ich wurde damals auf eine reise durch
den südpazifik auf einer schiffsreise
durch den südpazifik von den
wetterverhältnissen an diese klippe an
es ist eigentlich keine insel ist eine
klippe verschlagen und ihn hinein in
diese geschichte von der ich dann eben
erfuhr dass die rapa nui die bewohner
der osterinsel
diesen zahlen unglaublich kann
unglaublich weit weg von allem
menschlichen leben entfernten ort für
die heimat ihres alles erschaffen für
die heimat ihres gottes gehalten haben
es ist so weit weg dass man es nicht
mehr auf der auf der auf dem globus hier
sieht wir haben uns zuvor noch gesucht
sie schreiben ja in diesem kleinen
wunderbaren büchlein arznei gegen die
sterblichkeit das erzählen ich habe es
zu beginn gesagt eben eine arznei gegen
die sterblichkeit sei und wenn ich mir
jetzt so ihr ganzes behörde anschaue und
das ist noch nicht mal alles dann haben
wir ja eine ganze apotheke erlebten
damit länger sie oder ich
vermutlich sie wie ich beim erzählen
geht es ja nicht darum dass der erzähler
sein leben verlängert sondern dass er
die gestalten die er zur sprache bringt
oder neben tragödien komödien sehnsüchte
in sprache verwandelt aus der zeit
heraus
hebt gewissermaßen ich habe ja ein buch
begonnen dieses buch etwas eines
ängstlichen man es zum beispiel wenn sie
mir diesen hinweis noch erlauben zum
beispiel
mit dem hinweis
geschichten ereignen sich nicht
geschichten werden erzählt
also zu beginn ganz zu beginn dass eben
die verwandlung von etwas in sprache
nicht einfach ein bloßes abbild dessen
ist wovon berichtet wird oder was
beschrieben wird sondern stellen eine
tatsächliche verwandlung und 1 1
transportieren da der faktischen
realität in etwas was sich den regeln
des faktischen nicht mehr zu unterwerfen
braucht und worin besteht jetzt in
diesem dieser umwandlung auch denn für
sie genau die arznei
die aktie hat viele wirkungen lindernde
aber keine heilende wasser sterblichkeit
anbelangt aber sie hat lindernde wirkung
denn wie wir ja alle wissen in unserem
leben haben wir die menschen mit denen
wir leibhaftig noch auf dieser welt sind
aber die zahl derer die schon woanders
sind die nicht mehr da sind die wir nur
noch in unserem kopf oder in unserem
herzen oder in unseren geschichten also
in unseren erinnerungen haben dass die
zahl derer immer größer wird her bis wir
schließlich uns diese zahl dieser dieser
gruppe von menschen dieser familie
anschließen
und das die geschichten die man die wir
und wie man sich über sie erzählt halten
natürlich nicht nur die erinnerung
lebendig sondern in gewisser weise auch
die vermissten verschwundenen
erzwungenen menschen selbst also es ist
ein
überdauern es geht um dieses überdauern
dass man in geschichten und leute auch
im gibt geschichten erinnern kann
weshalb eigentlich auch dieses große
bedürfnis für den mensch doch immer
wieder
dazu werden zu überdauern die die
pyramiden sind ein großes
erinnerungsstück zu sagen an menschen
naja weil natürlich
der tod für viele menschen für die
meisten ziemlich traurig ist also die
aussicht dass das leben wo immer es auch
besteht wie glücklich oder oder
vielleicht auch wie dramatisch das war
einfach ein unwiderrufliches ende haben
wird und da ist natürlich das erzählen
eines dieser mittel
dass uns das uns befähigt über unsere
eigenen aber auch über die lebens
grenzen unserer liebsten hinaus zu
denken hinaus zu leben es gibt ja dieses
maßlose maßlose worte ich habe mich
lange mit dem
videos problem so videos naso
beschäftigt und der hat am ende seines
werkes damit harmlosen geschrieben ich
habe nun ein werk vollendet das dem
reisen und dem feuer standhalten wird
selbst den zorn gottes unter alles
vernichtenden zeit wann immer er will
macht der allmächtige nun mein leben
beenden aber ich werde mich mit diesem
werk über die sterne emporschwingen und
mein name wird unzerstörbar sein ich
meine das war natürlich größten wandel
klar er hat euch ihr habt ja das ist
sehr spannend was sie sagen weil es also
sie sprechen auf dieses buch ja wir sind
da raus geschrieben haben sie haben
einen großen fundus an mythen aus dem
sie schöpfen sie sind aber auch sehr
katholisch aufgewachsen ihre mutter war
sehr katholisch heißt sie kennen die
bibelgeschichten extrem gut kommt aus
dieser tradition die sie auch als kind
mitbekommen haben ihre große erzählung
ist könnte man das so sagen
wahrscheinlich mehr die höhe und
leselust denn für mich war das spannende
an der traditionen der ich aufgewachsen
bin
vor allem das alte testament
ja weil diese unglaublichen blut
geschichten und schlachten und
heimtückischen
überfälle und alle ausritte aus allem
und jedem was man sich als und unter
unmenschlichen vorstellen kann das hat
mich auf eine auf eine seltsame art
fasziniert weil es eben sehr dramatisch
weil es eben auch unglaublich gut gebaut
war als geschichte
und weil es mich weit weg geführt hat
weil es mich hat es ist sozusagen das
war die erste form einer kopf- und
herzens reise ich bin mit den philistern
damals mit den philistern schweinische
ganz böse leute
weiß gott wohin wie man sagen könnte
gereist und habe sie begleitet
schimpfend und verfluchen war aber ganz
an ihrer seite und mit ihren feinden
oder mit ihren oder mit ihren
objekten der sehnsucht und
nicht der sehnsucht agiert
und das hat mich fasziniert dass man ein
buch aufschlägt zunächst habe ich es ja
nur aufgeschlagen weil ich nur bilder
drinnen sah und habe meiner großmutter
und meiner mutter zu gehört die mir
daraus vorgelesen haben das war für mich
ein
motiv so schnell wie möglich lesen zu
lernen dass ich diese reise diese reisen
auf eigene faust unternehmen konnte du
bist ein man sich auf die mutter und die
groß angelegte genau sie haben jetzt
dieses buch jahren geschrieben die
letzte welt das ist ja auch wenn ich das
richtig in erinnerung habe 88 erschienen
das ist das werk mit dem sie dann aber
aus schriftsteller auch wirklich
unabhängig wurden ist das richtig ja und
sie haben davor als chauffeur gearbeitet
auch als reiseleiter man muss dazu sagen
sie haben aber eigentlich philosophie
studiert haben ethnologie studiert im
nebenfach astronomie sie haben eine
promotion eigentlich begonnen und sich
dann für diesen weg entschieden weshalb
haben sie sich weshalb haben sich da
schon dem reisen so zugewandt weil darum
geht sollte man ja zunächst war das
reisen oder dass das reisen als
reiseleiter
was geht und so weiter
natürlich nur eine von vielen
möglichkeiten das studium zu finanzieren
und eine die mir natürlich näher lag
wenn sie denn erreichbar war oft blieb
er dann doch wieder nur die werkstatt
die fabrik die baugrube die baustelle um
die nächsten monate zu finanzieren
und das war im vergleich dazu war
natürlich die verdient das angebot mit
einer gruppe von leuten durch europa
oder nach indien zu fahren
verführerisch aber
[Musik]
es hat mich natürlich auch insofern mehr
und mehr zum erzählen gebracht weil sich
weil sich über eine reise nach indien
oder oder in den himalaya keine
philosophischen also keine sinnvollen
philosophischen seminare seminararbeiten
schreiben lesen sondern
bericht geschichten eben ich frage
natürlich auch deshalb weil ich ein
bisschen raus finden möchte wie kamen
sie denn eigentlich also technologien
philosophie es ist das gar nicht und
naheliegend oder diese aber wie kamen
sie überhaupt diesem zu dieser reise
sehnsucht von dem woher sie ursprünglich
kommen eben dass sie diese promotion
auch begonnen haben und dann abgebracht
naja das war wahrscheinlich eine folge
der bekämpfung des heimwehs eines
geradezu
überwältigen heimweh sie hatten das kind
als clean hier war also in dem
augenblick wo ich mein dorf wo ich auch
nur wie mein bruder jüngerer bruder
stefan auch
in österreich sichtweite des hellen
gebirges und des toten gebirges
also ein vor alten dorf wo wir wenn wir
nur denn die das kreuz des kirchturms
aus den augen verloren haben kamen es
schon die tränen trotzdem warten sie mit
erzählungen immer wegreißen ja weil es
dann einige erfahrungen gab die mir
zeigten seltsam die ängste die da
bestehen was das was geschieht wenn
nicht wenn ich meine vertraute umgebung
hinter mir lassen und mich plötzlich
wieder wo wiederfinde
wo ich weder die sprache verstehe noch
die kultur noch die landschaft lesen
kann und so weiter und so weiter
dass das gegenteil von dem was
befürchtet wurde ein trat nämlich
manches mal ein unglaubliches glück
nämlich das glück dass ich erfahren habe
dass man egal wo das geschah und das
geschirr die die konzentrischen kreise
um einen vertrauten ort wurden sie ja
immer größer egal wo ich war hatte ich
dann das gefühl
es gibt nicht überall einen punkt in
dieser fremde aber irgendwo einen an dem
ich mich nur zurückfallen lassen muss
und es wird mich jemand auffangen also
dieses bei glaube ich psycho seminaren
sehr gerne geprobten dieser geprobten
übung dass man dieses vertrauen auf ihr
einfach grässlich hinten her also dieses
gefühl hatte ich ausgerechnet dort wo
ich wo ich
ursprünglich annahmen dort ist bedrohung
also da wäre ich verlassen und allein
und ohne hilfe
gespannt darauf kommen kommen wir sehr
gerne noch zurück weil sie jetzt das
reisen angesprochen haben ich habe mich
gefragt wie muss man sich denn
eigentlich den christoph ransmayr als
reisenden vorstellen sie sprechen von
sicher nicht als wanderer zwischen
welten wie ich zu beginn sondern oft als
tourist weshalb wie muss man sich sie
als tourist ja das war ein titel denn
den nicht angenommen habe weil die
erfahrung natürlich so reichhaltig und
überwältigend und von einer großen
schönheit auf die erfahrung des fremden
war oder die enträtselung des fremden
bedrohlich bedrohungen gab es natürlich
auch bei reisen in kriegsgebiete zum
beispiel
aber habe ich doch immer erfahren egal
wie sehr ich mich beschäftigt habe mit
dem ich war natürlich der sprachlose
idioten so dass das ist eben genau der
der interessante punkt weil das ist das
was in mir an klingt wenn man von
tourist spricht das ist für mich immer
auch ein modus der distinktion man
erkennt touristen oft schon aus der
ferne die laufen langsamer die stehen
irgendwie anders rum und die werden
immer in der nicht in der 1 in einer
fremdsprache angesprochen und ist zum
beispiel finde das ein total und
irgendwie ein unangenehmer motors ja ist
es auch ich habe mir das ja nicht
ausgesucht dass ich dass ich der tourist
bin also der sprachlose von sage mal es
nur aus der perspektive der rapa nui
oder eines anderen kleinen sind sagen
wir in zentralafrika events oder gebirge
die erkennen ich fühle mich nicht als
tab zunächst aber die wissen genau dass
ich einer bin
weil sie sagen ja was was weißt ja von
unser von von unseren jagdtechnik
fischerei tüchtigen was kann da
überhaupt fünf worte in unserer sprache
sprechen können sie kennt ja ja ich habe
immer versucht ein paar worte zu lernen
um einfach nur das bemühen zu zeigen
dass ich tatsächlich einen kleinen
brückenschlag auch zu den menschen die
ich da besuche oder ich frage ja ich bin
ja der der lernt die können von mir
nicht viel lernen weil
wenn man was will man von einem deppen
schon lernen
also vielleicht würde ein tab nicht so
viel schreiben aber das können wir ein
andermal besprechen aber spannend der
sehr genau dass diese brücken schlagen
deshalb habe ich die diskussion
angesprochen wie schafft man es denn
überhaupt diesen menschen trotzdem wenn
sie ihn für einen tab nicht zitieren sie
jetzt erhalten wie kommt man zu diesen
leuten wie schafft man diesen
brückenschlag
also es funktioniert es ist immer gut
wenn es so etwas wie eine wechselseitige
hilfe gibt also wenn man ein paar
handgriffe im stande ist mitzumachen mit
den menschen wenn man sich anbieter und
sagte ich hälfte das boot über den sand
ziehen oder wenn du willst fahre ich mit
hinaus zum beispiel
kann die aber umgekehrt auch ein paar
andere dinge zeigen oder vielleicht auch
geben eine stirnlampe zum beispiel wobei
das natürlich nur dort sinn hat wo es
dann auch nach nach dem lärm der
energiereserven auch noch batterien gibt
wenn es die nicht gibt dann ist dann ist
es viel besser wenn ich die technik
wiederum von meinem gesprächspartner
mehr aneignen wie wir mit zwei stück
holsten feiern das kann man immer machen
und sie sprechen aber auch jedenfalls
habe ich das irgendwo gelesen von
tourist sein als lebenshaltung und da
habe ich mich gefragt was meinen sie
denn damit wenn das eine lebenshaltung
ist
also ich würde das wort lebenshaltung
glaube ich habe ich noch nie in meinem
leben verwendet denn es ist schlecht
überliefert ja kann sein aber ist ja
auch zulässt korrigieren wenn man das so
verstanden hat dass ich das so gesagt
habe ist das natürlich zulässig weil
dann überlegt dass sie auch in meiner
verantwortung meine sachen so
auszudrücken dass sie nicht in dieser
oder jener hat missverstanden werden
können aber es ist natürlich
es ist eine gewisse die das status des
touristen ist eine gewisse statistische
angelegenheit also bei vielen reisen
haben hier und hier und da und in diesem
land nur den status des des sprachlosen
ahnungslosen besuches anderswo wieder
auf reisen die ich auf die ich auf eine
andere art mich vorbereitet habe weil
ich selber zum beispiel recherchen
betreiben wollte dann ist es wieder
etwas anderes und
und natürlich über alle grenzen und
barrieren hinweg ist es immer dieses
immer
eine art von liebe wenn man die ebene
erreicht indem diese beiden der besuchte
unter besucher eine art von von
liebes ebene erreicht nur auf ihr auf
einer art des gegenseitigen respekts und
der zuneigung nicht ich sage halt auch
ein bisschen emphatisch liebe dann
spielt dann fällt das ab also das feld
sozusagen dann fällt das seltsame
zellophan raschelnde silberpapier kleid
des touristen ab und zu steht nur noch
ein nackter oder halb nach der tat in
badehose
das können wir ein bisschen weiter
spinnen dieses dieses abfallen auch das
des kleides das ja auch metaphorisch
gemeint ist während der pandemie hat
eine bord von blaise pascal viel
verbreitung gefunden dass nämlich das
größte unglück des menschen darin dass
er nicht ruhig im zimmer oder alleine im
zimmer bleiben können und wenn ich jetzt
auch nicht unbedingt blaise pascal
widersprechen möchte dann würde ich
sagen sie würden durchaus widersprechen
oder also vielleicht kommt zu viel
unglück ja auch einfach von zu viel
stubenhocker rey ich glaube dass der
größte teil der stubenhocker rey und
auch alle diese schauerlichen vorurteile
die dann auch wiederum wie die daten
zusammengetragen werden ja in diesem
urigen stuben
dass die dann natürlich auch für die
ihre wirkung haben und es findet sich
dann schon der aufgrund dieser dort hoch
aus diesen fenstern der stübchen hoch
dampfen urteile auch alles mögliche an
gewalt betrug und so weiter veranstalten
also ich hab immer ich war immer davon
überzeugt
selbst wenn ich
selbst wenn ich noch so schon ganz nahe
an einem ort an einem geografischen
kindheits ort war dass man das da
draußen also jenseits der grenzen
irgendetwas liegt was mich einerseits
einerseits ängstigt und mir schmerzen
bereitet wenn ich über nicht in meinem
rücken meinen meinen kirchturm versinken
sie
andererseits ich mich aber darauf etwas
zu bewegen
wo es wirklich viel zu gewinnen gibt
nämlich nämlich das interesse wenn nicht
vielleicht sogar die zuneigung am leben
des anderen eines anderen und nur das
muss aber erlebt werden das ist
natürlich kann ich
reisen auch in dem ich lese lese lese
bücher lese aber immer ist irgend jemand
da draußen tatsächlich gewesen also auch
wenn ich sage mir reicht humboldt
aber er war dort und er hat unfassbar
viel ertragen für das was er an wissen
und
wirklich an einem so umfassenden
weltverständnis mitgebracht hat das
natürlich die anderen die nicht los
gezogen sind davon unglaublich viel
profitiert haben was nicht da noch
wunder nimmt weil wir jetzt viel über
das auch das zwischenmenschliche und
eben vorteile und zu sprechen gibt es
für sie in diesem reisen auch so was wie
eine sehnsucht nach dem ganz anderen sie
haben zuvor den den weg zu gott
angesprochen gibt es auch eine sehnsucht
machten ganz anderen den göttlichen
irgendwie sowas dass sie da auf reisen
also so explizit würde ein reisemotiv
würde ich somit zumindest natürlich ein
reisemotiv nicht fassen aber es ist
natürlich immer eine einer sehr
bewegenden manches mal erschütternde
erfahrung im gespräch mit den menschen
denen man dann irgendwo begegnet oder in
eben einfach nur im gemeinsamen sein zu
erfahren dass für diese leute
dort etwas bedeutung hat auch im sinn
weil religiöse bedeutung hat dass ich so
dramatisch von dem unterscheidet worin
und selber groß geworden ist und dass
diese erweiterung man muss sich ja dann
nicht anschließen dann muss ja keinen so
zusagt weder in diesem noch die andere
richtung eine mission prozess
beginnen sondern nur die bloße
erweiterung dass das dass es möglich ist
die welt oder auch das universum auf
eine vollkommen andere art zu erleben zu
begreifen das ist ganz spannend sie
haben hier ich muss schauen soll sehen
sie das ist so groß man muss schon
man muss schon stein auf stein
in diesem buch der fliegende berg da
haben sie einen wunderbaren satz drin
sie schreiben von der suche nach dem
unverrückbaren ort und einem
unverrückbaren himmel und irgendwie
klingt das ja so ein bisschen nach dem
verlorenen paradies
suchen sie auch nach dem
sehr viele unserer ganzen sehnsüchte
gelten an gelten einem solchen ort oder
einem solchen zustand an dem man sich
vollkommen
vollkommen geborgen fühlt frei von jeder
bedrohung
den gedanken an die unsterblichkeit wagt
man lieber nicht auszusprechen weil der
so klar dass er falsch ist aber
aber doch eine eine
eine innere bewegtheit die oder
besänftigung weil es da gibt es ja
dieses so unglaublich oft zitiert wer
aber trotzdem immer noch so wunderbare
wort von von ernst bloch mit dem er
seinen prinzip seine prinzip hoffnung
beschlossen hat in dem er gesagt hat
wenn er von heimatsprache heimat wäre
das was allen in die kindheit scheint
und worin noch keiner war
also da habe ich mir gedacht so
der spricht mir ins herz als ich das zum
ersten mal gelesen habe als als
philosophiestudent also dass das was man
für das alle vertraut dass der
denkt hält sie den ort das dorf der
kindheit dass das eigentlich eine ups
nach und nach schritt für schritt zur
utopie wird zum unerreichbaren ja fast
so eine paradies vorstellung aber dies
scheint dann eben auch zurück also darin
kann man ja auch dann hoffnung haben wir
haben die natürlich ja klar ich bin und
dann zeigt sich aber auch dass das was
man mit diesem mit diesen vermeintlichen
oder tatsächlichen paradies in dem die
eltern und alle liebsten unsterblich
waren und es also zumindest für
privilegierte menschen wie mich uns ja
die so leben durften und nicht in den
ruinen städten
zerstörten ruinenstätte aufwachsen
mussten dass das etwas ist was
dieses bild einer einer seele quasi
seligen zeit dass das immer eine ein
traum wahr und je näher wir diesen traum
wieder irgendwo kommen wenn dann sucht
man dann natürlich auch wieder ich habe
dann
in südostasien oder in
brasilianischen dörfern in afrika oder
indien tibet immer wieder
lebensformen gesehen da konnte ich eine
weile dann mit ein paar wochen oder auch
nur tage wo ich plötzlich ganz zu hause
war also obwohl ich die sprache
natürlich nicht verstand aber wir haben
gemeinsam gearbeitet sind gemeinsam die
berghänge hinauf und haben und haben
weiter gesucht
also das war eine unglaubliche erfahrung
die mich sozusagen zurück geführt hat
aber in eine utopie in ein paradies dass
es in wahrheit nie gegeben hat als ich
roger williamson die enden der welt
gelesen habe musste ich auch an sie
denken und umgekehrt und rohre
williamson der leider schon verstorben
ist hat eben auch sehr sehr viel übers
reisen geschrieben und er war mal hier
in der sendung und hat zum grund des
reisens folgendes gesagt wenn ich die
enden der welt bereisen dann kann ich
sagen an allen enden der welt sehe ich
den rückzug von natur sehe ich das
sterben von natur sehe ich das ende der
schöpfung auch und das zu vermitteln
legitimiert zum teil das aufwändige
reisen an diese orte nicht alleine aber
auch das wäre die nächste instanz eine
qualität des blicks eines blicks der
sich weg wendet von der sehenswürdigkeit
und der in einer situation ankommen will
in einer umarmung in einem duft also ein
ganz anderes ankommen hat das könnte den
zweck des reisens anders definieren also
bisher getan wird in dem augenblick wäre
vielleicht das unterwegssein das nicht
ankommen vielmehr reiseziel als das
ankommen so etwas zu vermitteln schiene
mehr an beiden polen der sachlichen
information und der formalen information
nicht unwichtig
ich fand das ganz interessant dass er
auch sagt reisen ist wichtig diese form
des reisens auch um in einer situation
in einem duft in einer umarmung sagt er
sogar an zu kommen und ich habe mich
dann gefragt braucht es dafür denn
wirklich dass reisen wie sehen sie das
oder wie reagieren sie auf wenigstens an
sich ja ja da sind wir sozusagen vieler
hinsicht dreißig gefährten
was diese position anbelangt aber
meine erfahrung und zwar ganz besonders
jetzt wieder in den letzten jahren
letzten zwei jahren wo die die geplanten
routen die mich dahin oder dorthin
hätten für sollen nicht möglich waren
wegen der pandemie und ich dann wieder
verstärkt zu fuß gegangen oder nur in
den allernächsten europäischen raum und
die vielfalt unter zauber und sogar auch
die exotik der allernächsten gegen
wieder so
schlagend wirklich im wahrsten sinn
schlag and wurden
das dort plötzlich erfahrungen waren in
dörfern von der nicht oder oder
landstriche regionen in dem nicht dachte
da würde ich nicht so viel mehr neues
finden weil ich schon so oft da war das
dann plötzlich wieder viel ist vieles
noch mal anders und neu zu sehen war
also man muss nicht dafür verwenden und
es sozusagen die distanz zum zum zur
destination zum ziel wird immer kleiner
immer kleiner immer kleiner bis man am
ende sagt ja wenn wahrheit wenn ich in
irgendeiner souterrainwohnung von
flüchtlingen gehe zum beispiel jetzt
oder oder in ein lager in einer ein
leser hallen wo hunderte und leute vor
dem krieg in der ukraine geflüchtet sind
oder vor anderen ja noch anderen legen
schrecklicher weise
dann sind in diesen hallen in diesen
zelten in diesem auf dieses sumpf
straßen erfahrungen möglich die es an
ihre erschütternden größe und intensität
mit jeder weltreise sozusagen aufnehmen
können das ist das ist ein sehr
spannender punkt weil ich wollte es eben
genau auch fragen ob es ob sie das auf
einen gedanken nach unterbrechen könnten
der für sie durch das reisen der
fruchtbarste oder auch ertragreichste
gedanke war den sie dadurch gewonnen
haben aber jetzt sagen ja sagen sie
eigentlich das umgekehrte nein das ist
sowohl es somit also auch wenn es geht
wo es geht ja und das wird einem jahr
gerade
auch als einfacher tourist irgendwann
bewusst es geht beim reisen immer immer
wenn es denn wirklich reisen sein soll
immer um den weg zu den menschen in also
optimieren und gegenüber sitzen in
seiner eigenen stadt und wir erzählen
aus welchem land oder aus welchem glück
sie kommen oder ob ich sie treffe weil
ich weil ich ein kapitel in irgendeinem
roman an der ostküste sri lankas
recherchieren will und damit einer
kriegspartei zu tun habe ist dann
plötzlich egal es geht wirklich um den
weg zu den menschen und der ist da wie
dort gangbar und dieser weg zu den
menschen der ist ja immer wieder oder
kannte auch geprägt sind von vorurteilen
von voltaire gibt ja auch diesen satz
wir tragen unsere vorurteile bis ans
ende der welt und das fand ich würd ja
ich hatte zuerst fand ich das irgendwie
so ernüchternd und dann habe ich mir
gedacht na ja man kann das ja auch
einfach umdrehen man kann sagen ja man
trägt gleich da sonst der welt aber dann
lässt man es dort liegen und dann habe
ich mich gefragt was ist das eigentlich
was sie zurücklassen wenn sie an einen
ort gegangen sind was bleibt dort von
ihnen
also ich habe immer mehr daran gedacht
was habe ich mitgenommen
was dort zurückbleibt sind beziehungen
die weiterhin gepflegt werden also die
man natürlich ist es bei der
über viele jahre hinweg nicht möglich
ständig irgendwelche
freundschaftsbande zu geben aber man
kann man weiß dort ist ein mensch und
ich bin ich bin ich da wieder hinkommen
kann ich mich an ihn wenden und
umgekehrt kann er sich an mich wenden
also es bleibt ein
beziehungsgeflecht
zurück und oft natürlich auch
weil sie von vorurteilen gesprochen
haben die angst was könnt ihr mir da
passieren die kampa sun gemahlin in
osttibet sie ja bekannt kriegerisch und
robuste
und dann sitzt man aber mit diesen
leuten da und nichts nichts nichts von
dem was nun vielleicht befürchtet hat
tritt ein also das bleibt dann auch
zurück dass wir zu sagen das ist eben
das vorurteil das anliegen dass dann das
wird dann sozusagen im nomaden lage am
feuer verbrannten ja jetzt gesund jetzt
haben wir so viel über das ende der welt
gesprochen ich habe mich gefragt sie
wissen es bestimmt wo ist das eigentlich
ja jeder jeder für uns jeder
erreichbaren punkt weil das ende muss ja
erreichbar sein damit wir es als ende
erkennen
und da hat sich da hat sich dann
herausgestellt
dass der globus wie eine discokugel von
lauter leuchtenden punkten bis übersät
ist und jeder punkt bezeichnete das ende
der welt finden sie denn in diesen enden
der welt in allen ihren reisen immer
wieder wirklich das neue und das andere
und das fremde oder doch immer wieder
und da kommen wir jetzt ein bisschen
auch diese vorurteils geschichte zurück
das altbekannte weil das ist etwas das
ich kann spannend finde oft denkt man
sich ja ich möchte jetzt ein abenteuer
ich kenne ich gerne einen anderen ort
und trotzdem reproduziert man ja für
sich sich selbst
eigentlich in der altbekannten manier
oder schaffen sie es wirklich auch in
der fremde wirklich ein neuer zu werden
oder sich auch anders zu verhalten
na ja das wäre
also in dieser
wiedergeburt schritten will ich noch nie
unterwegs gewesen aber
es ist es ist natürlich so dass
vieles aber das liegt im instrumentalen
bereich also ich erkenne wieder die
probleme die es gibt in einem tal mit
dem zählt erkenne wieder auch da das
prozedere an diesem oder jenem fährhafen
oder flughafen also ich bewege mich
eigentlich leichter deswegen weil ich
weil ich das schon oft gemacht habe und
immer wieder mache aber was dann
wirklich passiert
das ist nicht absehbar ich kann mich
erinnern ich war mal mit einem
russischen eisbrecher
am nordpol also zunächst am franz josef
land und dann am nordpol und dann stand
ein
maschinist an der reling das weil der
hocharktis
und es war wirklich
360° bruch ins packeis
unternehmen himmel hell und mögen die
natürlich die großen aktiven mögen die
den eisbrecher noch von franz josef land
her kommend begleitet
und dann sagte er zu mir
soll ich dir was zeigen vater mich
wirklich gefragt ob ich interessiert bin
und ich hab ja ja wunderbar hell und
dann streckte er die hand aus und
rief hatte einen schrei ausgestoßen ja
und da war zunächst nichts und dann noch
einen schreiben auch ein paar minuten
kam plötzlich aus diesem eisen grauem
himmel eine eine große mühe und setzte
sich auf seinen armen will der vogel
also war ganz klar wir waren unterwegs
das war nicht so dass man irgendwo eine
station oder es war ein zweifelsfrei
ein zweifels für mich zweifelsfrei
wunder
und ich sagte wie es wie machst du es
war eine zufalls entdeckung
er hat das einfach nur mal probiert und
dann kam ein und es geht nicht jeder
möge sagte ja
das war also und wenn es selbst wenn es
nur
diesen schrei gibt
das ist
etwas sohn das ist wie wenn man durchs
schlüsselloch in ein an in einen anderen
spiral nebel schaut
ich wollte einen einen bogen eigentlich
zurück machen wir hatten zuvor schon mal
über ihre herkunft gesprochen wir haben
schon gesagt sie sind aus oberösterreich
heute haben am trauen fall sind sie
aufgewachsen und dass diese herkunft
kommt bei ihnen immer wieder in büchern
vor zum beispiel jüngst in diesem fall
meister hier
dort ist auch ihr vater geboren und die
großvater war eben einer der letzten
fall meister dass jemand da die
wassermengen reguliert bei einem
wasserfall und ich habe mich dann
gefragt weil das eben bei ihnen auch so
vorkommt und wald ebenso viel unterwegs
sind was ihnen genau diese herkunft
bedeutet
ja also das war für mich damals ein sehr
dramatischer ort das dorf in dem ich
geboren bin liegt
ja genau
sehr lobenswert dass sie dieses bild
noch auf und mein urgroßvater war der
letzte fall meister der 1909 und riesen
system weil er nur dazu da den saals
transport aus dem inneren der berge an
die donau
das hindernis dass dieser fall
darstellte zu überwinden und durch bots
kassen die dann zu gehen auf eine
spezielle weise geflutet wurden und die
boote abgesenkt in den und alonso weiter
in den unterlauf
des flusses für mich war das einfach
weil das war ein scharnier
dieser fall die dramatik dieser dieser
wasser was kultur der felsen und des
flusses ich bin ja vor allem am fluss
ausgewiesen die hat mich verbunden mit
meiner lektüre mit den geschichten also
dieser wasserfall und diese fluss ließ
sich sozusagen wunderbar
zum mississippi von von von
huckleberry finn
umdenken oder um empfinden oder
irgendwelche indianische oder natürlich
in die auch in die donau an der dahme
richard löwenherz gefangenen saß und von
seinem sänger blondel
singend gefunden und alle und so weit
also da begann sozusagen an dieser traum
wirklich dramatischen situation weil
oben ist ja alles felder
walddörferstraße
alles das mich nicht besonders
beschäftigt hat aber da unten schien das
meiste sucht sehr viele so wie es immer
schon war stimmt natürlich nicht und man
muss ja nur auf den gleisen sagen aber
ich glaube dass trotzdem so erlebt in
der gründliche nach vorn und dieses
saniert da diese gewaltige fall der im
gewaltig ich meine wenn sie in
schaffhausen der fall ist das ein
kleines plätzchen
aber für mich war es gewaltig
dass der dann auch zuvor und dann
plötzlich heißt würde mir von 10 12
metern glastürme vor mir stand still was
gerade noch tost gebraucht und getrost
hat ein stille ein stille riesige
skulptur also das ließ sich auf eine
wunderbare art verbinden mit meiner
bloßen fantasie und wenn wir noch mehr
über die herkunft sprechen und um dieser
fantasie die da gespielt hat dann ich
habe es zuvor schon angesprochen dass
ihre mutter eben sehr religiös war sie
waren dort priester denn sie sehr
gemocht haben sie haben ministriert sie
waren eine benediktiner schule ich habe
mich dann gefragt was ist eigentlich von
dieser prägung wenn wir jetzt von dieser
anderen von dieser wasser prägung
sprechen was ist von dieser prägung
dieser ganzen das ist der ganze
nachricht religiösen bildung eigentlich
für sie geblieben bis heute das sieht so
aus wie man ein foto als negativ und das
positiv betrachten kann ja und ich habe
nur noch das negativ weil
die erfahrung was geschieht was mit
einem gedanken
auch mit einem gedanken der aufklärung
oder auch der liebe geschieht wenn sven
sr wenn dieser gedanke oder die prediger
oder verkündet dieses gedankens sich zu
einer so genannten glaubensgemeinschaft
zusammenschließen das hat nicht
abgestoßen also
ich war leidenschaftlich gern ministrant
wegen des
wirklichen mordtat dass das der start
fand auf latein noch dazu konnte ich
auch ein bisschen angeben in dem ich
diese gebete alle aufsagen konnte man
zwar nicht wusste was sie bedeuten aber
ich konnte es ein auffassungen zaubert
ja ja das war ein zauber das war sehr
und in verbindung mit einem mit einem
erzähler der dieser fahrer war der
großartig war wirklich ein großer
komiker ein menschenfreund und ein
toller musiker und gitarrist ich habe
das alles als als wirklich heißt diese
sogenannte kirchenjahr mit den feiern
zur hose da drüber nach los angeles ja
wir hatten ja weder ein auto noch ein
telefon noch ein fernseher kino sowieso
nicht er also der größte das größte
theater das stattfand fand in der in der
dorfkirche stand ja und sie waren mitten
drin und ich war natürlich mit toll
adresse also
rot für die märtyrer grün für die ganzen
hoffnungs heiligen also was waren ihre
lieblingszeitung der welche farbe naja
das war insofern ein bisschen unpassend
aber weil sie war die eleganteste
schwarz
das hat sich bis heute gehalten
naja das hat ihm reisen zu tun weil also
ich würde jetzt nicht wenn wir eine
schwarze soutane
aber es ist halt wahnsinnig unangenehm
wenn mit einem gepflegten hemd jemandem
was zu fragen oder auch was zu bieten
oder versteckt dann alles ja verstoß war
ich meine man kann es ja trotzdem am
nächsten tag wieder wechselt das hemd
aber es ist ja nach dem frühstück wenn
ich glaube sie wollten ja dass ich in
einem wegen der hintergrund studio
hintergrundlicht rosaroten rüschenhemd
kommen lassen wir uns am liebsten
gerissen ich wollte ihn sogar meines
amtlichen
aber weshalb komme ich eigentlich so auf
die herkunft zu sprechen das hat auch
einen grund sich haben im fall meister
und in diesem atlas aus dem sie zu
beginn vorgelesen haben eine sequenz
zweimal verwendet nämlich über den fluss
tom leezer penh kambodscha und die hat
mich unheimlich beeindruckt weil es
offenbar so ist dass dieser fluss einmal
pro jahr die flussrichtung wechselt
werden dass hier sieht man sieht hier
auch den fluss man sieht leider den
fluss denn die fließrichtung wechsel
sieht man nicht aber was der macht der
geht zurück zur quelle und deshalb auch
diese diesem diese fragen zu ihrer
herkunft weshalb haben sie denn diesen
genau diesen aspekt auch doppelt
verwendet was hat es mit ihnen zu tun
dieses zurück zur quelle weil es für
mich ich war zwei mal da was in
kambodscha
und also jetzt erst einmal unmittelbar
nach nach dem verschwinden der
niederschlagung des pol-pot-regimes also
in einer schrecklichen blut landschaft
und habe zum ersten mal dort gedacht ich
hätte das war ein riesiges
missverständnis in der regenzeit
der tonle sap ist ein nebenfluss des
mekong also ein der mündet in den mekong
am königspalast in kambodscha und wenn
der ton der mekong in der regenzeit
steigt sein spiegel bis zu elf und zwölf
meter und wird sozusagen zu einem wasser
wahl zu einer wasserwand
die den einmündenden fluss tunnel es ab
zurückdrängt wieder ins hinterland der
breitet sich dann natürlich auch wieder
ein riesiger strom und see und ich habe
mir gedacht das sogenannte wasserfest
wäre dass man das fair das feiert man
dass das 1 1 strom einfluss zurück ganz
eine quelle sowie wenn wir zurück
könnten in den schoß unserer einheit und
mutter susanne aber das war ein
missverständnis das fest gilt nicht dem
quasi wunder dass ein fluss ein strom
seine laufrichtung ändert sondern am
ende der regenzeit sinkt der spiegel des
mekong wieder und der unterton des
abkehrt sich wieder um unter der
damalige frühere könig von kambodscha
hat im hat im rahmen dieses festes dem
fluss bevor sich zu besinnen und nicht
zurückkehren sozusagen an seinen
ursprung als eine quelle sondern soll
dorthin fließen wo alles hin fließt
nämlich ans meer und an die auflösung an
die verdampfung soll sowohl die werden
und als wollte weder als dann als regen
hagel oder eben in unserem bei als
schnee
herabregnen auf unseren also dann feiert
eigentlich dass die natur wieder zur
besinnung kommt er zur besinnung genau
und ich habe es einmal so und einmal so
verstanden weil für mich was am anfang
unglaublich dachte ich war sie da sein
das musste einfach sein das war die
sensation nicht dass du einfach alles
wieder seinen lauf nimmt wenn wir an
einen anderen ursprung zurück gm zu wie
sie überhaupt erzähler wurden da habe
ich was dabei weil ich wollte die frage
stimmt es wirklich dass sie durch das
hier gelesen kamen ihrer durch die
buchstaben zum verhör das überleben von
ihnen ja ja meine mutter ich wollte ja
ich habe ja so dringend schon damals vor
den bildern des alten testaments
lesenlernen gewollt aber noch war aber
erst fünf nicht mal 5 und meine mutter
hat dann gesagt ja also wenn es so
wichtig ist
ich glaube kommt kann man ja mal spielen
und ich habe diese suppe ist sehr gerne
wusste schon dass das buchstaben wenn
ich einzelne buchstaben erkannte ich
erwähne an den geschäften und so und
dann hat sie mir sozusagen aufgereiht an
tellerrand weil die gekochten die klebt
mehr schön und verschiedene worte
zunächst ja und was sie bedeuten und für
mich war das reinste magie also dass man
da ein wort das auch nur drei
verschiedenen buchstaben besteht wie
mehr mgr drei bis vier buchstaben
das bild der brandung von inseln palmen
küsten schiffe alles mögliche aufbauen
kann das ein wort das in meinem kopf
zum zum aufblühen bringen zur explosion
fast bringen kann das war ein aber das
war ein spiel also das war keine
schulstunde das war ein zauberhaftes
spiel und so haben sie ja man wirklich
durch dieses spiel für sich auch das wie
soll ich das formulieren so die dick das
mysterium der sprache auch kennengelernt
wieder genau an
ein anderes mysterium ist ja irgendwie
auch die gedanken entstehen über die man
schreibt über sie reisen und und erleben
der dinge und irgendwann wird es jedes
jahr zu einer geschichte und sie sind
seit ja aber muss man wieder suchen
seit dem buch die schrecken des alls und
das sind dann ist ja auch mit dem
extrem-bergsteiger reinhold messner sehr
gut befreundet und genau darüber wie
eigentlich die großen geschichten
entstehen hat mein kollege yves bost mit
ihm gesprochen wenn wir kurz zu wir
gehen ja freiwillig aus der
zivilisierten welt die relativ sicher
ist der mensch tut seit 10.000 jahren
nichts anderes als die welt seine urbane
umgebung sicherer und sicher und sicher
zu machen da gehen wir hinaus in eine
menschenfeindliche welt wo man umkommen
könnte
um nicht umzukommen das ist ja das ist
wichtig dass diese möglichkeit bleibt um
zu kommen wenn die möglichkeit nicht die
möglichkeit um zu kommen nicht vorhanden
ist ist das ganze nur ein spiel aber
wenn die möglichkeit umzukommen gegeben
ist dann gehe ich gegen meine instinkte
in die wildnis ich die instinkte wollten
das nicht sie sagen du hast angst und
ich habe auch angst und sorgen trotzdem
durch sich gegen den
selbsterhaltungstrieb das ist der
stärkste trieb den wir haben da hinauf
um nicht umzukommen und wenn es mir
gelingt nicht umzukommen ist das
anschließend wie eine wiedergeburt und
das ist vermutlich der hintergrund warum
wir das immer wieder tun dass da eine
art wiederholungszwang auftritte sagt
nicht eine sucht da sind ja keine opiate
im spiel höchstens körpereigene aber es
hat einen wiederholungszwang in sich
weil dieses wiedergeboren sein dieses
gefühl wieder geboren zu sein ein sehr
starkes gefühl ist
die ich das verstehe sagte also auch
dass die die großen gedanken immer auch
an den grenzen zum tod jedenfalls
retrospektiv entstehen und da habe ich
mich ihnen gefragt sie haben es zuvor
auch schon angedeutet hilft ihnen denn
für ihr schreiben auch das
ungeheuerliche
es ist so dass sie das sind natürlich
reinholz reisen zumindest die in die
höhe und durch den jahr haben natürlich
eine vollkommen andere voraussetzung für
mich war wir haben ja viele reisen
gemeinsam gemacht aber wir waren aber
eben nicht nur im himalaya und dem
transfer
am ortler
das sieht ja fast aus als ob ich mich zu
einem irokesen durchgekämpft hat
schade aber sie das heute nicht das
ginge nicht
also für mich war dann reinhold zu sein
die garantie dass ich nicht um kommen
werde wenn er dabei ist ich war also
durch die durchquerung ost i pads oder
wir waren ja dann auch in dem südpazifik
und in brasilien und im ruwenzori
gebirge und so weiter also war er immer
auch für mich ein garant ich wäre hätte
einige regionen in denen ich gereist bin
ohne ihn nicht gemacht weil mir dazu
einfach die überlebensfähigkeit gefehlt
hätten aber trotzdem stellt sich die
frage welche rolle die angst zu reden
das ungeheuerliche für sie spielt sie
schreiben ja nicht ohne grund den titel
atlas eines ängstlichen mannes da
sprechen sie auch von ihnen und offenbar
hat dann angst schon auch eine pure
kraft
das natürlich aber es ist etwas anderes
diese angst auch der gedanke an den tod
muss nicht der sein der mein eigenes der
jetzt mein eigenes reisen fortkommen
bedroht weil zb dieses buch die
schrecken des eises und der finsternis
so habe ich den rhein und auch kennen
gelernt er hat mir damals einen brief
geschrieben weil er gedacht hatte ich
wäre ein akt des reise und da ich war
damals und das war sie gar nicht mehr
örtlich der punkt war kopenhagen hatte
keine ahnung hat ja noch nie noch nie
einen eisberg gesehen oder arktische eis
parker ist
hier war die niagarafälle sehen kann ja
das war klasse erfolgreiches jahre aber
ich hatte meine quellen damals eben nur
als lesender also ich habe viele leute
die überlebt haben die denn oder auch
die gestorben sind dann später daran
die von ihren ängsten von dem von dem
drama des ihres abenteuers zu dem
übrigens zum beispiel immer wieder am
unsinn sagt der abenteurer oder der der
expedition scanner ober nun zum nord
oder zum südpol geht
nimmt abend teil in kauf aber er sucht
sie niemals auf
also dass abend heißt eigentlich
entsteht wenn etwas misslingt oder wenn
den naturgewalt übermächtig wird und
plötzlich unkontrollierbar
sie reisen hier arbeiten nicht nur auf
der welt sondern auch im kosmos und in
mikroskopisch kleinen sehe ich sagen
soll was sie sein so was wie ein hobby
astronomen hat sich denn für sie das ist
ja ein extremer dimension wechsel auch
als mensch hat sich für sie da der blick
als mensch auch stark gewandelt mit
dieser form des reisens der quasi in den
verschiedenen dimensionen nach
ja es ist so dass ich habe ich habe zwei
sonnenteleskop rund fünf
hektar also himmels stern tele5
reflektoren und spiegelteleskop und
blicke da immer wieder immer wieder mal
tour natürlich
nicht aber
es ist oft wirklich ambivalent ich habe
in den jahren der zum beispiel eine
krankheit war diese blick oft
erschreckend also der sich dann
tatsächlich
verliert irgendwo also man verliert sich
quasi in den weiten in den ungeheuern in
den ungeheuerlichen räumen und den
geschichten weil da geht es ja um
geschichten da verliert sich selbst die
geschichte eine so winzigen und gemessen
am ganzen bedeutungslosen trabanten wie
die planeten wie die die welt das ist
auch ein gut das wird ja oft wird ja oft
immer herbeizitieren herbeigeredet man
fühle sich so
winzig dass
habe ich mich nie gefühlt ich habe mich
umgekehrt immer unglaublich
unverständlicherweise kostbar gefühlt
gedacht habe
unfassbar in diesen räumen in denen wir
jetzt mit triumph ein paar exoplaneten
entdeckt von denen wir jetzt schon
wissen da gibt es wahrscheinlich nichts
was unserem leben auch nur annähernd
gleich wie kann es denn sein dass in
diesen räumen die in dieser
ungeheuerlichen weite nicht nur einfach
ein paar bakterien entstehen oder ein
kleines pflänzchen sondern wesen die das
alles auch mitdenken können ja die sich
schon denken
erzählend rechtschreiben formulierend
berechnend über das alles erheben können
das ist unfassbar
also das ist für mich ein großes rätsel
aber trotzdem ist diese
ungeheuerlichkeit also was jetzt
dimension anbelangt in situationen in
denen es einem hier da in dieser kleinen
welt nicht so gut geht auch
bedrohlich also für mich gibt es dann
auch in der nacht manches mal an in
denen einer nacht in der man allein von
den teleskopen sitzt und nach einem auch
noch einen vorgezeichneten reiseplan ich
mache mir dann pläne für eine nacht um
das teleskop relativ wenig bewegen zu
müssen
das hat auch mit genauigkeiten zu tun
aber selbst in winzigsten räume ich das
teleskop nur sozusagen fast unmerklich
bewege bin ich in tausenden millionen
von lichtjahren unterwegs sind dann
legen sie richtige strecken zurück
richtige strecke eine richtige
busstrecke für den sonntags astronom
wir kommen schon langsam in die
schlusskurve unseres gesprächs etwas
nimmt nicht nur wundern ich habe nämlich
gelesen dass hier nicht nur eben
kosmischer kosmisch reisen und
mikroskopisch und überhaupt auf der welt
sondern sie hatten auch als jugendlicher
zumindest haben sie auch halluzinogene
reisen also trips gemacht sie haben
haschisch an angepasst oder direkt oder
nicht dann schrecklicher weise die
pflanze war so wirkungslos dass ich
genauso gut kamillentee hätte
schmeckt nur wenig am hut
hat es irgend etwas miteinander zu tun
weil so halluzinogene trips das ist ja
auch eine form von reisen ja schon aber
das ist sozusagen glaube ich das war
damals
aber man in den zeiten der jahre an der
universität war das ja einfach ein
eigentlich auch ein schlüssel her indem
man versucht hat ob sich das bewusstsein
tatsächlich erweitern lässt und hatte
sich erwähnt aber
ja und nein weil es ist so wenn man
einmal durch ein fenster man kann das
natürlich immer wieder machen wenn man
einmal durch ein fenster in eine
vielleicht sehr fremde und
ungeheuerliche landschaft geschaut hat
dann kann man das fenster immer wieder
aufmache immer wieder aufmachen aber man
wird sich dadurch nicht besonders
verändern außer vielleicht zu einem zum
nachteil dabei ist also wenn sie sagen
eine fensteröffnung war sieht man dann
da weil man das fenster gehört ja da
können sie einiges sehen
das ist seine einzige fernsehsendung
viel zu kurz
nein aber das ist ja dass ich sie auch
geschichte ich habe durch meinen damals
gab es leute wie die propheten dieser
gezielten und systematischen
drogeneinnahme werfen meskalin ist lässt
natürlich hatten wir
diese leute denen ist man halt oder für
die ethnologen war denn carlos castaneda
und die lehren des don juan
haben wir natürlich auch in der weise
gedacht wir müssen uns dieser diesem
lehrbetrieb anschließen dann schauen wir
mal was die zuschauer sehen wenn sie aus
dem fenster schauen das ist vielleicht
noch etwas letztes zur reise sie haben
mal gesagt
in bezug auf ihre letzte reise dass auf
ihrem grabstein auf und nach front
stehen sollte und wenn das jetzt auch
unernst das palaver gewesen sein sollte
oder isst dann klingt das nicht
unbedingt nach letzte ruhe
naja aber die gibt es ja auch in dem sie
nicht
ja weil in dem in der vorstellung dass
sie sie nicht
als als als materie als kultur so sagt
winzigste bausteine auch in uns sehen ja
möglicherweise
das eine oder andere teilchen vom
tutanchamun noch wirksam oder oder noch
noch eines älteren weiter in der
geschichte zurück liegenden
herrschers oder oder auch nur eines
webers teppichknüpferei flötenspieler
also
was mit uns geschieht wenn wir uns
auflösen in der jetzigen form ist ja
sozusagen ein prozess der beginn eines
prozesses der ihn zu irgendwelchen
anderen
zu wägen durch anderen kombinationen
wieder führen wird also man lebt quasi
in seinen einzelteilen irgendwo ja ich
kein großer trost ja
aber mein gott immer sagt halt dann auch
besser als gar nicht
gut dann denke ich mich für diesen doch
halben trost und für dieses gespräch
ransmayr ja dankeschön für die
gastfreundschaft haben sie einen
gedanken reichen sonntag und bleiben sie
uns gewogen
[Musik]